North Korean media is not commenting on
outside speculation about leader Kim
Jong Un's health Reuters new j news
agency says china has sent a delegation
including senior doctors to advise on
Kim's condition there are rumors that he
is seriously ill following a heart
operation satellite images from North
Korea monitoring site appear to show
Kim's private train at the resort town
of one Sun on the East Coast for more on
this story I'm now joined by Aidan
Foster Carter's senior research fellow
in sociology and modern Korea at Leeds
University in the UK Aidan it is
notoriously difficult to get reliable
information about the state of affairs
in North Korea several media outlets now
are now quoting sources in China saying
that Kim has actually died what are your
source is saying about Kim's health I
should hasten to say that I'm an analyst
I don't have any better or different
sources than anyone else I'm trying to
put together as many people are the
pieces of a jigsaw puzzle we don't have
enough pieces and we certainly don't
have any picture on the box to guide us
anything anything is possible it is
interesting that he missed a key meeting
that was the first alarm his father's
birthday at the 15th the big holiday
son's day they called it he's never
missed that it's also interesting
perhaps the only other definite fact his
train has been seen at once and on the
East Coast as you said that is not near
where the arrest report said he had for
surgery
I do think anything is possible I think
it's right to talk about it even as we
assisting that we only have we have
unconfirmed rumors because if he if
anything is wrong with him and I'm
non-committal on that at the moment
because we don't know then we can be
fairly sure that that is a very big deal
for North Korea it's a very resilient
state it's managed to successions before
but there's absolutely nobody in place
now so we will just have to wait and see
he may pop up and surprise us all and
those of us who speculated may have egg
on our faces as happened before but it's
a very big
if there is something wrong with him if
there is indeed something wrong with him
it is unclear who would succeed him as a
leader who's the most likely candidates
and what if there is no clear transition
of power indeed so well long ago this
was a communist country where they
weren't supposed to be monarchs and
heredity and there are those who think
that you know normal service in that
sense could be resumed some committee
could take over I don't think so because
they have gone down the monarchical
route they don't call it that of course
but they call it the pic Dumont sorry
take to bloodline after the big volcanic
Mountain which is richest sacred so it's
got to be in the blood it's been it's
gone you know father to son to son that
nice he's got children we think but
they're very little indeed he has got a
sister kim yo-jong she's very able she
is has a more public role a recently she
issued two statements in her own right
but it's a very sexist or the post
Confucian patriarchal culture and she's
very young too so that would be a very
big deal there's a there's a half uncle
kim jong-il probably haven't got time to
go into all the details he was a
long-serving ambassador well away from
Pyongyang in several East European
countries I think most recently the
Czech Republic very able again but women
is acceptable it's it's really hard to
know they could easily be a power
struggle the army which was much more
powerful under his father Kim jong-il
and Kim Dragon has reigned back they
might make a paragraph it's very messy
and whose hand would be on the nuclear
button
lots to worry about Aidan Foster Carter
thank you very much for this analysis
thank you